salut à tous et dans médi pour brut je
commence sur le terrain mais mais je
vois très vite que sur le terrain ça va
pas être ça va pas être forcément
possible et j'ai un entraîneur qui me
met dans le but à cette époque non ça me
faisait pas rêver du tout moi j'avais
envie de courir marquer des but célébrer
avec eux avec mes potes 2014
c'est la fin de ma troisième année à
cherbourg quand je me retrouve sans club
c'est en discutant avec mes proches et
ma mère qui me dit d'aller faire un
dossier à pôle emploi pour percevoir mon
occasion chômage c'est la désillusion
dans se dit c'est un rêve qui s'effondre
un objectif qui qui sera in athéniens
parce qu'on parle de trop loin on
on se dit que bah c'est peut-être pas
fait pour nous d'avancer arrêter le foot
à ce moment là oui oui j'ai pensé
arrêter le foot j'ai pensé arrêter foot
plus d'une fois même temps durant cette
année
[Musique]
j'allais signer dans une boutique de
prêt-à-porter mais que j'ai eu l'appel
de l'olympique de marseille et ce qui
m'a permis de de continuer sur le foot
c'est quelque chose pour moi d'inespéré
parce que je suis au chômage et et quand
vous êtes au chômage bat plus personne
ne s'intéresse à vous j'ai vu ma mère
pleurait parce que elle était content
pour son fils elle savait que bah il
avait une chance de se relancer
qu'il avait bas qu'il allait avoir un
contrat qu'il allait pouvoir subvenir
aux besoins de sa famille mon côté je
viens me voir et me dit il me dit
et d'où il ya il ya à lui si c'est qui
qui t'attend à l'extérieur du vestiaire
qui veut discuter avec toi donc moi
franchement je me dis ah oui le
sélectionneur sait qui s'est déplacé
pour moi c'est quelque chose
c'est quelque chose que j'imaginais même
pas deux mois avant et donc bah je le
vois et en fait il n'a même pas besoin
de parler parce que ils venaient prêcher
un convaincu a été franchement facile
pour toi de choisir de porter les
couleurs du sénégal ce que tu aurais pu
être à l'euro aussi oui oui c'est vrai
que j'aurais pu j'aurais que je aussi
pour la france mais mais c'est comme je
lé toujours dix mois depuis depuis tout
petit c'est c'est pour le sénégal que
que mon coeur penche de la france s est
aussi mon pays
mais le sénégal c'est le coeur c'est
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
expliquer en fait les joueurs on veut
dire qu'internet jeudi que des c non à
part à part ngolo pascal bolo je les
croisais ans en national quand il était
à boulogne-sur-mer en séance à affronter
personne ne connaissait même les
français me connaissaient pas au final
je mène nulle part
et j'arrive dans un club où tu as des
tas d champion du monde cadet champion
d'europe et moi j'arrive dans sa g j'ai
27 ans c'est
c'est compliqué de se dire qu'on va
qu'on va rentrer dans ce genre de
vestiaire et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
être performant directement sur le
terrain de 29 mai 2021 on arrive au jour
j c'est là la finale de la ligue des
champions
c'est quelque chose que que même
certains grands joueurs ont jamais vécu
et moi pour ma première participation en
ligue des champions j'arrive à atteindre
la finale avec mon équipe c'est c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel
je sais même pas encore si je réalise
totalement le fait que j'ai remporté la
ligue des champions avec chelsea et
et je me rappelle du coup de sifflet
final quand j'ai vu mes proches sur le
terrain en pleurs c'est là que je me
suis rendu compte de l'ampleur de ce que
ce dont je vais accomplir au moral de
mon histoire je dirais que c'est le fait
de ne jamais abandonner
oui là vraiment jamais lâché et comme
ils 19e